.
I APPRECIATED, PLEASE KEEP GOING
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IF THAT SEEMS OUT OF CONTROL IF
YOU'RE STARTING TO CONCLUDE THA
THE FEDERAL AGENCIES ARE OUT OF
CONTROL AND HAVE HAVE TALKING
POINTS UNRECOGNIZABLE, HERE IS
SHOCKING STORY, YOU REPORTING
FROM THE WEBSITE REVEALS THAT
DOJ BEGAN SPYING ON THE U.S.
CONGRESS IN 2017, SPECIFICALLY
THE DOJ SOUGHT GRAND JURY
SUBPOENAS FOR PERSONAL E-MAILS
UNTO STAFFERS ON THE INTEL
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS RIGHT AROUND THE TIME
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE WAS
PROBING THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
HOAX.
DEVIN NUNEZ YOU WOULD THINK
WOULD BE BEYOND ATTACK BY THE
AGENCY SINCE HE WAS THE CHAIRMA
OF THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE AT
THE TIME, HE WAS THE GUY
OVERSEEING THE INTEL AGENCIES.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE WASN'T, WE NOW
KNOW.
, WE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
I SHOULD SAY IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
WERE SPIED UPON AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
NOW THAT WE KNOW IT PRESSURE?
>> AT THIS POINT, TUCKER, IT
APPEARS TO BE THAT IT IS NOT
JUST A COUPLE OF STAFF, IT LOOK
LIKE IT IS PROBABLY MORE.
WE ONLY HAVE A COUPLE OF
SUBPOENAS AT THIS POINT, SO THI
IS PROBABLY JUST THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG FREIGHT WHAT THIS IS IS
REMEMBER, THEY TARGETED MY
LAWYERS, SO IF YOU GO BACK TO
THE TIMEFRAME OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING, WE WERE IN A BRAWL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI BECAUSE WE CAUGHT
THEM SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND OTHER REPUBLICAN
OPERATIVES IN 2016.
THAT CONTINUED INTO TO 2017.
AT THIS TIME WE HAD CONFRONTED
HIGH-LEVEL FOLKS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI SEEING THAT
LOOK, WE THANK YOU GUYS MIGHT
HAVE A PROBLEM HERE TO COME UP
MAYBE YOU SHOULD RECUSE YOURSELF
, MAYBE YOU SHOULDN'T BE
INVOLVED.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN TO THE BOTTOM OF IT THAT
WHAT THEY DID IS THIS CUTE
LITTLE WAY A REVERSE TARGETING
ME BY GOING AFTER MY STAFF TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DID WE KNOW THIS
INFORMATION, WHAT WERE WE GOING
TO DO WITH THIS INFORMATION AND
THIS WAS ALL JUST MONTHS BEFORE
WE MADE THIS ALL PUBLIC THAT TH
FBI USE THE CLINTON AND DNC DIR
TO SPY ON TRUMP AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: YOU CAN'T HAVE A
DEMOCRACY IN WHICH UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS WITH GUNS CONTROL
ELECTED OFFICIALS FOR THAT IS
NOT A DEMOCRACY.
WHY DOES NOT ANYONE BURN THIS
DOWN AND START IT AGAIN.
IT IS A BIGGER THREAT THAN ANY
OTHER FOREIGN GOVERNMENT FREIGH
WHY DOESN'T ANYBODY DO ANYTHING?
>> WE TRIED, TUCKER, AND WE MAD
14 CRIMINAL REFERRALS, I ASSUME
JOHN DURHAM HAS THAT.
A LOT OF THESE REFERRALS DID
INVOLVE LYING AND MISLEADING
CONGRESS, THESE ARE ALL THINGS
BY JOHN DURHAM, I KNOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO CLOSE IT DOWN, BUT I
THINK CONGRESS, MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES SHOULD BE PUSHING
THIS INFORMATION TO LOOK AT THI
BECAUSE THIS IS CLEARLY IN THE
REALM OF WHAT THEY JOHN DURHAM
SCOPE WAS TO LOOK AT PERRY I
KNOW HE BROUGHT SOME CASES IN D
AND AGAINST CITIZENS THEY HAVE
POWERS THAT APPEAR TO, NOT
APPEAR TO, THEY DID, THEY TURN
IT AGAINST THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WE WERE DOING OR TO TRY TO
GET BLACK MALE HONEST.
>> Tucker: IT IS VERY CLEAR
THAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
BEING DEVI